son merci d'être là mon génie mohamed
parce qu'il travaille beaucoup du mit et
ils nous répondent à toutes vos
questions et c'est vrai que nous apprend
beaucoup de choses tous les soirs merci
jimmy d'être là merci beaucoup merci
mais un train intercity mis alors à l'an
passé où à logbaba avec les questions
pour 10 me mohamed et jetez vous êtes
très très très nombreux à poser des
questions ça et c'est les questions si
pratique et ça cartonne un je vous le
dis tous les soirs le allô docteurs
cartonne ya aussi des questions pour les
chroniqueurs les cherry et on n'a ni mac
et est détenu ni maquette avec nos
bonsoir bonsoir nîmes à 11 à nous
maintenir mais ça l'unima merci d'être
là comment ça va mon chéri à tout va
bien tout va bien tout va bien tu nous
appelles domont ni ma voix nous avons
cherché à le mée sur seine dans 77 à des
proches qu'il avait bien hâte avec qui
c'est ton fils à côté moi c'est moi
c'est ma fille ils sont trop mignons ils
sont trop mignons et j'aime bien la
coupe la de ton fils l'aï la viande bien
là c'est bien plaqué là c'est frais ça
hein
ouais mais c'est qui c'est quoi pour toi
les montées et basse est redescendue et
ben c'est un amour comme ils s'appellent
les données deux enfants ça ça c'est
issa et sa web et maya et ben ils sont
magnifiques merci d'être avec nous merci
mon chéri ton confinement tech toute la
famille ouest avec toute la famille love
et ben merci paraît que c'est une
question pour nos attitudes pourquoi
dans la ville ira pour laurence à
laurence sailly et vas-y à battre alors
laurence avec des faussaires de
maîtresse d'école
alors je me suis demandé si tu pouvais
avoir une relation intime avec quels cas
de 15 ans de moins que toi oh oh bah je
peux te donner la réponse c'est oui
ah oui non là laurence alors asie répond
répond que ça ne compte pas n'a pas fait
à passer qu'un important ce qui compte
c'est l'intérêt c'est la coi à l'accord
1 est bien avancé l'intellect
ça te plait s'anima moins raté son
mandataire pas là où adacore avoir été
complètement ouf toi et lui il est
tranquille ya sa meuf à l'étagé il est
tranquille en train de chez les u9
tranquille
ali doit tout cas face non mais nima il
est tranquille où bill ou la non mais
comment bon ben atiq c'est hostile au
plan sauvegarde
je peux faire bouger le bois voit pas
mal ouais pas mal mais pas le fan de
séries et merci pour ta question tu
aurais pu me dire comment je pourrais
devenir syrie j'avais autre chose à
vas-y mon image tu sais que moi j'ai un
métier pas comme les autres je suis
artisan glacier
ouais alors après le confinement je te
propose de venir à l'émission est
d'offrir des glaces à tout le monde à la
mairesse est particulière de faire de la
glace c'est quoi c'est grâce aux
installations prix s'est passé c'est
avec ton c'est pas avec ton sexe non
avec les maritimes avec emma avec
plaisir c'est ce que tu veux avec thema
d'accord on a assez bon bah écoute
ramène tes morts amènera les foules
ok je te fais un gros bisou et et grieg
autant on va le faire passer sur wii il
n'y a pas de souci je viendrai pas de
souci je te fais un gros bisou frérot
merci d'avoir sali new way serait resté
chez lui et sa famille on vous fait gros
bisous tu as une famille est que c'était
une famille très très belle t entends de
son magnifique à tapas tombera sans
mention je n'ai pas fait descendre mais
c'est la descente dès la naissance
n'avait pas les tiny elle n'est pas bon
allez on brasse la halle et je tombe
rokia bientôt bas merci motesharei mais
c'est beaucoup
il est très sympathique et je suis très
chaud la journée mais il m'a donné envie
de manger une glace tu sur pied vous
aussi lâché qu'une envie c'est d'aller
prendre une glace sur ma vie frère tu te
rappelles quand il y avait là toujours
un camion frère on va à côté de l'école
la frère où ils vont des glaces le club
et tu sais pas pourquoi frère la glace
est meilleur que partout sur ma vie
c'est à dire qui et comment comment vous
font dire et dans son camion frères et
soeurs dégâts elles ont jamais eu aussi
froid de mon frère mais par contre la
glace son frère elle vaut 15 balles ça
veut dire frères
quant à mr le matin elle te dis d'accord
tu vas pouvoir acheter une glace à la
pente d'école mon frère sa veux dire
toute la journée tant contrôle
d'histoire-géo mon frère tu pense qu'à
une chose c'est aller chercher la grâce
à la fin de l'école mon frère et tu sais
bien que tu vas aller prendre la glace
au caméo mon frère tu peux faire une
queue de 8 heures vous faire pour avoir
la glace maintenant tu as la même
sa boulangerie mais tu veux la glace du
camion c'est vrai ou par les mecs sans
rigoler c'est un truc non c'est comme
les camions pizza traire les cannois
pizza tu passes devant le camion pizza à
faire la pizza on dirait n'ai jamais vu
cette odeur ou frère on dirait qu'il a
sort du moteur moteur de camion de
glaces et la glace et tous et c'était
génial de cas des vrais frères quand le
camion de glaces il passe mon frère en
bas de chez toi à frère ambac ton email
mon frère c'est comme si faire sur la
tête de ma mère c'est le 14 juillet sept
dirigeants ils sortent pâles confrères
et on dirait qu'il ya des failles et mon
frère y croit la macro qui va passer
avec ma son de basse terre avec des
cornées comme un frère ça a pris 12
thedan c'est une histoire
dommage au-delà des questions
on a des questions pour - jimmy
mohammedia brigitte qui nous dit combien
du combien de temps dure la perte de
goût et l'odorat en cas de coronavirus
alors alors c'est vrai que c'est un
symptôme qui est fréquemment retrouvées
justement cas d'infection corner 2 il
faut rassurer les gens jamais vous avez
que ce symptôme c'est à dire la perte du
goût et de l'odorat centièmes
sans tout sans autre symptôme on
considère que c'est plutôt une forme
mineure en revanche si encore plus de ça
vous avez de la fièvre ou tina c'est
vrai plongé on peut penser que cette
réforme un peu plus importante à
surveiller
on sait que le goût et l'odorat doit en
principe revenir de façon spontanée
entre cinq et dix jours mais on ne sait
pas exactement sur quel intervalle et on
ne sait pas si tous récupèrera à la même
vitesse et de la façon intégrale
donc pour l'instant tout ce qu on
conseille aux gens c'est de pas mettre
trop de ce prêt dans le nez le spray
nasal puisque vous risquez de disséminer
un petit peu les virus éviter les
traitements à base de corticoïdes note
que sont opprimés ou les
vasoconstricteur ne fait rien patients
piste à doit rentrer dans l'ordre tout
seul qui a perdu l'odorat ou le goût là
dernièrement un an mais en quatre années
dans nom mathieu
non non non franchement j'ai de la
chance que ça va très bien
[Musique]
à d'autres questions pour 10 me juste
avant des questions de fabienne fabienne
qui est avec nous fabienne qui est à
vienne qui nous appellent de cusset tu
sais que c'est q c'est fabienne bonjour
fabienne civile
merci d'être là fabienne vous êtes
magnifique merci reid
merci beaucoup fabien tu as une question
pour qui ma chérie alors moi eh bien je
suis très heureuse de voir mathieu ans
parce que j'attends mathieu depuis des
jours et des gigues et jours
mais pourquoi ce qu'il me manque mais
pourquoi la solution peut être qu'il est
beau qu'il est pertinent parce qu'il est
drôle
bah oui les ceux qui derrière toi ma
chérie et là c'est ma fille qui par
contre c'est un fait je croyais que je
crois que c'est un filtre snapsan
t'avais me baï tf1 buy com à ce que
j'adore est comment elle s'appelle mieux
la lola pour lui faire un gros bisou du
défunt énorme bisou vous êtes en
confinement avec qui ma chérie on étudie
deux d'accord un super vache ou fait
d'énormes biz ou telle question pour
matthieu vesques sion qui s'est mise en
branle ce sport va dit ta question pour
mathieu à mathieu mathieu il y avait une
question
fabienne alors vas-y fabien ta question
vas-y pour manor mathieu mathieu si tu
voulais dire un mot juste un mot à ton
papa qui te regardent ce serait quoi
et si c'est un mot qui est trop
difficile
un geste où quelque quelque chose alors
alors annoncé alors à 1 alors on va
rappeler on va rappeler l'histoire parce
que ça m'aide apparemment connais
l'histoire
mathieu tu nous avais dit
de la première émission chez moi que
c'est vrai que tu parlais pas ton papa
je crois depuis deux ans maintenant ou
trois ans mais ouais deux ans trois ans
voilà douze ans et c'est vrai que bon
avec ce confinement mine de rien alors
on rigole un tous les soirs je sai baba
avec à l'aube avec ce soir chez ba ba
mais mathieu tu t'étais livrés c'était
vraiment tout le monde s'était reconnu
dans ton témoignage qu'il ya plein de
gens qui m'ont dit c'est vrai que moi je
vous rencontre pendant ce confinement
que j'ai parfois été voilà il ya des
gens que je vois plus alors je me dis tu
vois si je pensais pas que ça pouvait
arriver ça et que si demain je devais
plus revoir une personne avec qui je
suis un petit peu effritée c'est vrai
que ça me ferait de la peine
toi pour le coup c'est ton papa donc
c'est quelqu'un de très très proches et
c'est vrai que voilà les gens avaient
été extrêmement touché avait pensé la
même chose que toi avez dit c'est vrai
qu'on on se pose beaucoup de questions
en cette période de confinement en cette
période va là où on sait pas ce qu'on va
devenir demain où on a peur pour tous
nos proches pour tous les proches et
pour tout le monde d'ailleurs en
appelant tout le monde à moi c'est vrai
que j'ai pas pour tous les
téléspectateurs pour tous les français
mais on a peur pour eux est question
qu'est ce tu auras lui dire c'est la
question de fabienne rapidement j'ai
déjà je voulais jouer les remercier
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui très
gentiment c'est vrai sur les réseaux du
sba où vous êtes un peu tous parce que
toi tu es à la télé tout ça on est pas
tous et c'est vrai que je pense que
comme beaucoup de gens od au début j'ai
pris un coup sur la tête tu sais avec ce
confinement où tu sais pas où tu vas et
tu pourras coup sur la tête moral et
d'éloigner un peu et après tout
organiser une biture tu rebondis un peu
c'est ce qui est en train de m'arriver
donc tant mieux et puis je pense aux
autres et après sur mon père bien
évidemment pour l'instant c'est
compliqué charge les suffisent arts se
voit on peut pas bouger
j'ai eu des nouvelles par des gens de la
famille donc je sais qu'il est confiné
aussi que le temps passe qui vieillit et
que et que je je pense qu'en tout cas ça
fait beaucoup réfléchir je pense pas que
pour moi je voyais tellement de gens
seuls pour de la vérité écrit mme kim et
kris est tellement de gens seuls confiné
que je pense que ça fait beaucoup
réfléchir et ça permet je pense quand on
est sous le choc sans la période la
firme est de voir cette propres erreurs
et du coup à mon avis à la fin de tout
ça ça permettra à mon avis de faire un
pas comme tu m'avais dit quand on est
plus jeune vous parle pas ça devait être
un rendez-vous ne fera pas pour y aller
sarah terme et peut-être de nettoyer un
peu quelque chose qui se nettoyer pas
que tu sais quand tu t'arrêtes pas
finalement que tu continues tu avis bas
voilà mathieu on espère en tout cas que
ça va s'arranger que tu seras non papa
je suis sûr qu'il doit être comme un fou
et je suis sûr qu'il serait très très
très heureux sur parler j'en suis
persuadé merci fabienne pour cette
question gars aiment à bienne merci pas
d'hier